في قلبي ببدا احد ابواب المدينه العتيقه
في العاصمه التونسيه يتربع محل ولتحنيفه
ملك اللبلبيس كما يلقبونه على عرش الاكله
الشعبيه الاشهر منذ 40 القرن الماضي
اسمه حمودي حنيفه يسموه وقت على امه
وامه كانت امراه كبيره كبيره
ابراهيم ابراهيم
والشخصيات العامه من داخل تونس وخارجها
[موسيقى]
وصلت تبعث
ام كلثوم
الذي تحول الى معلم والصمود في الصداره
امام المنافس
همم البلاد العربي
الحانوت هيدي تراث من تراث تونسي
الله
يرحمها
خاصه في هذا العنوان ومن عماد الحريف
المصري الذي تحول الى عامل في محلفه الى
حلفاء اخرين يقطعون مسافه طويله نكتمتع
بنفس المذاق في نفس المكان
الثالث لبلبي عند ولد حنيفه من حب في
اللبلابي خدمت عند والد حنيفه بنينا نظيفه
ومشواره وقديمه عند الحاجب
البلابل
اخرين منذ زمن وهو بعضا من الذاكره لاجيال
المتعاقبه مرت من هنا لسباحه العربيه
احلام العبدلي تونس
[موسيقى]